so to start what is the biggest takeaway
or lesson from making sing one that you
are actually able to apply oh the
biggest lesson
uh
i don't know there's so many because the
trouble we make in these films is
there's so many aspects to it you want a
nice snappy answer and all i can give
you is i don't want a nice snapping
answer go deeper oh but jeremy it's one
of those things where you go oh it was
just everything it was like oh uh pace
yourself um make sure that um that
that's finding the flow of the character
stories keep it simple
keep it relatable always make sure that
the music
fits the story and the characters even
the funny stuff it has to
or fit organically and naturally you
can't just say i love the song or just
stick it in um
and uh but i suppose
my main thing to do is my main reason i
wanted to do a sequel was because i
could feel this of like
that the character characters could
handle it and and that chris mello
dandry and i just both had this passion
to see where they would go
is there any particular character arc
that was the toughest to you know crack
or
work into this particular story because
one of the things that impresses me most
about these movies is you have so many
different characters that all experience
a transformation and that's not an easy
thing to do in a sub two-hour movie no
it's true it's not easy and that finding
that rhythm to go from one story back to
another to another that's actually
probably the trickiest part of the
entire process to get that rhythm right
to make it feel natural and easy um
i don't know what what's the secret to
that
effort and trying and trying and and
being and making sure that you feel it
but the hardest i suppose the hardest
one for me was the clay callaway story
because it's dealing with grief
and you want to honor that and be
you know honor that feeling you don't
want to shortchange people and and be
sort of like superficial but at the same
time
you can't be too heavy because you're
going to then push people away so it's
finding that balance and that was the
one that we were fine-tuning right till
the end just how much you showed found
that balance very well i was very
impressed by that speaking of clay when
you conceived of the character did you
always know you wanted bono for the role
or was there ever a phase where you had
to wish you could say yes i was like
yeah of course i mean christmas andre
and i were like well bono could you
imagine
that voice you know that what he
represents as a rock like a rock star
he's fully embraced that and um
and also those songs of theirs are so
they're so inclusive you know what i
mean they mean a lot to people even if
you don't know you're hearing it as soon
as you hear it you feel included and uh
yeah so i yeah that was always what we
had in mind but i couldn't believe it
when he said yes
how about uh halsey because that was
that was one character that and like her
voice in that role popped more than i
think i was ready for so were you always
going like beeline right for her or did
you ever consider you know a wish list
there no again you don't think
everyone's gonna say yes you think well
let's see but luckily the first film
seemed to resonate with people and they
were interested in seeing how they liked
it so well how would they work in this
halsey
just can do can do anything
i mean every five minutes she's doing
something spectacular like whether it's
painting have you seen her paintings
i've never seen that they're amazing
they're like not just good they're
amazing and she obviously she's an
amazing performer and singer
uh and then turns up and just nails it
in front of the microphone being porsche
with real
gusto there wasn't like there's no like
half measure with her she was like i get
it and bang
um
you can't ask for more when you're
directing a film like this to have
people of you know that caliber give
everything they've got